I love that this show touches on queer
representation and you have always been
a huge ally for the lgbtq+ community
why do you connect to that community I
think that I just I just don't a world
in which people feel a certain pressure
to be a certain way or behave a certain
way is so absurd to me and I think that
there have been countless times in my
life where I've been in situations where
I feel that that sort of pressure and
and I don't anymore I don't feel like I
should and I don't think anyone should I
think everyone should feel free to be
who they are and true to themselves and
I I think having the show deals with it
so well you know in that time maybe they
didn't have the terminology of what we
have today in terms of describing a
human and maybe that's why they have I
mean you would think they had more
freedom then but it was it was almost
more forbidden then and and it's crazy
that in this show we still deal with
today what they were dealing with then
and although we've come a long way not
much has changed which is insane to me
but I just truly believe that everyone
is everyone is equal everyone is human
everyone has a beating heart and feels
the same feelings how the two of you fit
into such a tiny bit I don't give up